I know I had this great moment where I
was talking to travis willingham and
he'd already already beat it the second
one the second one
wow what a teacher's pet it's easy to
get through nice nice top access isn't
it Austin a week ago I was somebody it's
because obviously because of Laura Laura
got a code 19 I was kind enough to send
out a codes for you know actually got
one I got one
Laura got one of course and so Laura
powered through it and then uh and then
Travis got after it and look at this
perfect layer right here if you can't
see things it's like it's like almond
milk and then coffee and then you see
yeah it's like the burger that you're
never gonna get but I was talking to
Travis and I was like yeah dude I just
did this he goes wait what do you mean
you just did this my god I didn't he got
through that super easy he was like I
was stuck there for forever like no I
ain't gonna do is just do this thing and
so he's like super mad at me there's
like embargo will fully 100% be up and I
don't wanna spoil anything anyway but
there is like the pot of the game that I
got stuck in the most is such a brutal
pot to get stuck because basically there
are mines everywhere on tripwires it
took me a really long time to get
through it because sometimes I'm just
bad at navigating anyway but the problem
with taking a long time to get through
that and figure out what you have to go
is that if you [ __ ] up le explodes it's
so brutal and I did it maybe like four
times I'm just like oh my god I'm so
sorry and then not to spoil anything but
then did you realize the other way that
you could have gone I didn't realize
that and I got stuck there too and I was
like and it's the conversation ready
but there's like there's like there's a
there's a line of dialogue that starts
at when it responds you and I got so as
like oh my god and I hear this line
again because I'm an idiot
videogames it's so good but what about
the dinosaur part was that cool really
surprising also like I like the bit
where it turns into Pokemon snap and you
have to take as many photos of horses as
possible the aliens the aliens part was
weird but it made sense like in the
context as I'm shaking at least we had
William Hurt there to explain it so you
know all made sense did you just make an
AI reference is that what that was that
was a Jurassic part I mean a kiss
kingdom of the Crystal Skull reference
oh I forgot he was in it because I
forgot that movie good for you good for
you is that the right state it's not the
right state to be into no I've seen that
too not have seen it just just it's
funny because it has that film has one
of the most amazing iconic Indiana Jones
shots and it's at the very beginning and
it sets up what the movie could have
been don't defend this me right no it's
I will defend the first stone like 15
minutes because it's the beginning of
the movie promises that it's going to be
Indiana Jones having survived the
Rock'em Sock'em World War 2 serial
adventure has now found himself in the
cold
modern cold where cold war-era where an
old-fashioned hero does not belong it's
now an era of paranoia of nationalism
and and there's this thing where he's
being interrogated in a McCarthy sort of
way for not being sufficiently American
and it was and then and then it gets
trapped in this like nuclear test zone
and there's yeah yeah hold on hold on
don't just just like gloss over that
because that's Austin watch his movies
with his eyes closed
[Laughter]
we're gonna we're gonna get to it but
the the the the shot that we're the test
nuke goes off and it's the silhouette of
Indiana Jones against the shot of a
nuclear mushroom cloud movie blowing up
by the way I I don't I don't deny that
basically from that moment forward it's
it's a kind of successively
more aggressive trainwreck but I
remember thinking the idea of a movie
that is like it's like Indiana Jones
it's like a third one the strengths of
the third one and the pan the dynamic
with his father if it had been a fourth
one about about him saying what is my
purpose in the world now the world has
left me behind it I I belong to a prior
era that would have been a much altered
fool that's what you see that's that
would have been great because that's a
running theme throughout everything
right because bellick says that to him
in the first one he was like take this
whole thing you know if I bear it it's
worthless but if I buried in the sand
for a few thousand years because a
priceless relic and the beginning of
three was that I cannot take away yes
but he goes he goes it belongs to the
museum
so do you that whole thing right so
there's the whole thing that he's
they've already covered that ground by
the way I just end of want to point out
at least from my perspective it looks
like either Austin has matured or has
gone crazy and he has like this really
cool tree does look like you have a
little silver strip in here also and I
love it I do actually not an illusion I
really do have that because my hair is
so long it's way more obvious than
normal but yeah it's funny that always
my Connick mr. fantastic all right let
me go you do that I have one question
for Mike Bissell actually I have a
question for you okay my Bethel when you
wrote mr. Jones and me what were you
[Laughter]
twice no it's right now we're serving it
Troy
Austin wintry wait you always do it
respective it's not what's being
recorded video game at Detroit Baker and
videogame director Mike hello I got one
of those right is where's Mike none of
its right you look like a man with no
sense of am i it is Mike up there Austin
Austin Oh Mike join second Troy joins
lost this is the Canon okay
opinions are subjective and we may come
at things from different points of view
I wanted to ask you off the top of the
show if you comfortable talking about it
game reviews for lost was Potts who came
out Friday morning 5:00 a.m. did okay
did okay was it like a six outs alright
you guys can all wait on this really
it's it's a question that evil how much
weight do you put on that date like if
you're a person who's working on a video
game and you know exactly when the
embargo is up like for you Friday
morning at midnight did you stay awake
to read reviews how much attention do
you pay to that point in time basically
are you asking me first or might be
first you first I was not an option I
[Music]
think it changed for me especially like
I have my my watershed moments for when
like the the opinion and accolades of
others really kind of I respect them
they are right that we've talked about
this before is
far as like what game of the year and
and and stuff like that means to me but
specifically for like the reviews I
wasn't thinking about it just because I
have I think I've actively tried to
filter just what everybody's saying
about the game before it's out it'll
change come Friday but the way that
everyone has been talking about the game
is like you don't know and then I forgot
the fact that review codes went out and
that there are people that were actually
no I've played the game and then that
started to change when when people
started texting me and was like dude or
hitting me up on other ways and going
like I I just finished this just played
this and to see those things were like
okay cool your opinion is informed
because you've actually had controller
in hand and spent time in that world so
your opinion now at least has more
weight and more value is actually in the
old we've had to filter stuff out
because there's so much conversation
surrounding this game obviously but now
and it's it's both for and against
there's like no it's gonna be amazing
was like you don't know you could suck I
doubt it I mean just to given the the
statistical odds of the people that are
making this game and and what they've
done in the past like that their their
history is with them that it's gonna be
good at least good but play the game and
then tell me what you think
and so once people started saying I've
played the game and I think the first
one that I saw was God what was it for I
want to make sure they get credit
because they said it's exactly I didn't
they were basically they went to going I
don't think we needed to do this and
then I played the game and it changed my
mind it was like that's what someone
will say Esquire reading the tweet I
said like I intentionally spoiled myself
yeah and it didn't matter like it was
playing the game is what you have to do
because everything that gets spoiled
you're like so there's one particular
spoiler that I remember the only one
that I actually read the only one that
actually got spoiled for me that I was
like oh [ __ ] and then when I actually
watched the cutscene I was like well the
context of this and I know you said it
Troy it's like yes I should have
listened to you when you were like but
the context
everything whatever but it like the
context of it was so different to the
woods in terms of how I related to it
and how it made me feel like it is a
thing that made me like very angry but
when I was reading it I was like Bella
but then when I see it I'm like are you
[ __ ] serious but I'm not angry I'll
Bob Naughty Dog I'm angry like on behalf
of what the story is leading me to woods
and that was like really one particular
thing but it's obviously that but the
ways very different the the way that it
is so paced out where every beat is
going and knowing everything I'm still
like damn just from a pure narrative
standpoint and not just like story game
it's the way that those two blend
together and everything that I do like
the combat system in this game is the
best combat system that Naughty Dog has
ever done yes it is unbelievably
rewarding and I didn't some people will
agree with me on that it's it's like
mixed but I I didn't enjoy the combat in
the first game where is it this one I
actively really like it and look forward
to lodge combat sections but it's also
like there's some interesting stuff with
the way the infected and human enemies
might interact with one another so even
in those combat sections where you could
intervene
sometimes the best option is to watch
and then it's a scene that plays out in
front of you in gameplay that you're
like oh holy [ __ ] like there was a
little tiny bit of that in the first one
yeah a little bit you'll see the DLC
women's valve which I'd yeah today
actually left behind and talked about
and for me to also first time to finally
do that one I was lost yeah and like I
felt like something was missing but hey
I have so my best work in that the
Actors Studio perform your your key line
there's that's pretty good there's some
stuff it's quite there's some great
stuff that left behind did that added
weight to the first game retro actively
and I think that there's this is I
immediately wanted to play I'm like I
can't wait to play this game again you
know what I love just to jump in on that
you know what I love about that because
I literally I played the game whatever
seven years ago and never since until
this past week and and then on HeLa and
I kind of tag-teamed through it you know
a couple hours a night basically for
maybe about ten days and then and then
blitz through left behind
just in a sitting and the thing that I
loved about it I guess I try to avoid
things being spoilery even for old games
but something that I loved was that by
inserting a couple hours of storytelling
within that time jump into the winter
for like never mind the pre-meeting Joel
like the prologue aspect to Left Behind
but the actual real time looking for the
health the the medkit in the mall or
would that to me that is so much I'm so
glad it's a DLC that you play after the
game because the experience of seeing
what she went through to tee up all the
stuff in the snow with the deer like
that's so much more powerful when it's
your first experience as Ellie doing
that but then to later see that she's
got some mileage on her and we can
justify it we can explain it like it's
the perfect way to have parsed that out
in his windows where I thought man well
it also works really well good idea the
setup of the first game as it stands
even for me being a woman still made me
feel very much like a father figure to
Ellie so when you play left behind I
feel like you still have that same
attachment to well you you really sure
about her and really really want her to
be okay that's a really interesting
thing that happens in pot to you again
not gonna get into spoilers here at all
I will have a spoke
stop probably I think it's next week or
later this week I haven't decided what
date yet but is that the time to
actually freaking get through yeah okay
so because of the relationship that I
have to Ellie as a character but that
you also see Ellie matura and you you
watch her get smarter and be driven in
different ways because of the time jump
it also I still feel like her parent but
I feel like a parent of someone who has
grown up and become independent so I
have this like weird pride now like it's
just a very interesting relationship to
that character it's so unique my playing
of it that the thing that I love and how
the again the the way that the gameplay
of vaults to reflect the growth of the
character there's things that happen not
only is like an unlock as an upgrade
which the way you can upgrade your
weapons is super dope but even the way
that they did that is different than the
way they did this first game should all
be dead well here's the only thing that
I shake all peripherals now my thing is
more awesome no matter where you no
matter where you go if and it makes
sense but I don't hae went huh
everywhere you go whether when you find
a workbench what's the first thing you
do is you push the the power strip on
and the light comes on I'm like how long
those things lost it but even just the
way that you like it those animations
are informed by character the way that
she disassembles that weapon and puts it
down when you're gonna do an upgrade is
I don't know man it's there's not a
single thing that's that's not driven by
character so everything feels earned the
way that you fight is not only connected
to your specific style of gameplay and
the way that you want it to be
but but the gameplay is reflecting the
character it's [ __ ] great it's
[ __ ] great
I think I texted you this Troy but yeah
pots that brought me to tears and some
of them are actually completely silent
but now the the performances are very
very very good man I I agree
Jeffrey Pierce Jeffrey Pierce Jeffrey
Pierce I it is it dad dude my dyneins
just same last name oh really my dad's
name is Vince no I'm just making a joke
about the fact this name's Jeffrey
Pierce
oh that's my last name that's me it
appears Jeffrey Pierce's who plays Tommy
and I mean I cannot say enough about
that guy he is so talented as an actor
as a writer and what he did for Tommy is
just I think there's any moment of this
conversation that Mike and I don't feel
some level of English so I was going to
start making like if we were stable I
know I don't want to get too far away
from anything but at a conversation with
someone a lot if I can tangent there so
welcome towards the end do you think
mike bissell because of the way that
production is going right now how do
person ask me is like do you think that
we're gonna go back and work at studios
and i was like I really think that
what's gonna happen is that publishers
by and large are going to look at this
is such a
along as good as burn eyes every time
that someone in the in the comments on
YouTube is like you guys didn't talk
about thing that's in the headline what
I wanted you to know this is the moment
your boy - I've noticed actually in the
comments most of the time I'll see
somebody put a little timestamp for like
by the way they actually start I love
people now and comment like responses to
those going that's the show I I will I
will
I know well you learn many times before
unless my cough like is it was just a
question that I I looked at his face and
I was like I really want to know what he
thinks about this but it could be a
whole other podcast as far as like what
the future of gaming is so we'll just
use that as a team Wow but game review
the Box suggestion box yeah to jump back
to the question Troy is like do it
before other people was ultimately like
what you what you noticed about review
school is it was it just something that
you tried not to wait at all I was I
wasn't nervous I I actually thought I
was like it's probably gonna go there's
one of two ways that was going to go it
was either gonna go the way that it did
or I was gonna go death stranding where
it was gonna be this political statement
and people were like don't matter what
it's a hundred or no matter what it's a
zero and that the score was that is the
read that I have from most of my friends
we've played it is it's a hundred or
it's five it's very much that way and
that's for sure yeah a ninety six
Metacritic to ship it in 96 I don't but
dude we got have warship that a 95 is
that right not sure because so I mean
with the loss of his part to like I said
a lot of the the more middling reviews
are currently unscored and I don't know
if you guys knew this but Metacritic
eventually tries to give a score to
those unscored reviews so the reviews
that me the first week will change a lot
yes so this is basically Metacritic does
a thing with any unscored reviews they
have where they try to guess where it
would fall and apply that times its sign
yeah it's your scientific process as
well yes they're weighted differently
depending on who reviewed it so it's all
over the place
so you kind of have to give it a week
before your review scores even out but
yeah it's a it's a 96 right now based on
89 critic rookies which is you know 10
big numbers I texted Neil this with that
that morning when everything started
popping up and and I said while I resist
the temptation to be upheld by the words
and whims of the Vox Populi especially
when the majority of those voices belong
to the journalistic sector 44 perfect
scores feels pretty [ __ ] good most
raw that's the most Troy tags you could
do a whole episode about text ken Levine
reference I feel like baked into that he
actually texted Ken Levine the morning
bioship the fireflies that dance I guess
like how much weight do you put on
review schools is it something that
you're really nervous about is it
something that you wait for cuz I know
some Deb's like Cory we thought abour is
a really good example what he actually
recorded himself the best video ever
went up and he's crying and reading the
review schools
I love Cory one of my closest friends
and I'm that's the thing that I wish
every dev did because it's so nice to
see people's reactions but I also don't
like knowing that there's that much
weight
so why not swing well we said let's wait
it's it's complicated let me just before
I before I actually ask you guys the
pointed question I did want to this is
something that I spoke about earlier
this week in a video but there are a lot
of stats that back this up
I'm just pulling one from GDC in 2015
this is told by era America Holcombe who
gave a talk on the effects of Metacritic
scores on game sales I feel like the
public perception is that game review
scores are hugely important to sales and
statistics from every study I've read
say that that is not true game reviews
and discourse around games will
potentially make people who have already
purchased the thing feel more positively
or negatively going into it it does give
you bias but it doesn't tend to
influence sales so says the the CEO of
TBA games and her team looked at the
scores of 88 Xbox 360 games and 80 ps3
games from 2012 and compiled data from
Metacritic Game Rankings and VG charts
they plotted out the data and found that
Metacritic scores have no impact on
determining actual sales and like I said
they're plenty more of these that I
could read if you just google do game
reviews effects say so you'll need to
jump in as the the resident indie yes I
think the stats vary that's not
necessarily true our end of things you
need the exposure which is the big shift
my answers kind of your original
question which is for me I like on a
personal creative level I try very hard
so take exactly the same stance Troy
does where I make my met on my stuff and
either people like it or they don't like
it I'm gonna keep trying to make things
and see what happens however I'm
responsible for a company as well and
I'm responsible for a lot of people's
jobs and that means that on release day
it's actually a very tense kind of
horrific thing for me often we have
rituals we have we have the since since
Thomas was alone we've had the ritual
that we have the Pedrosa us who are
physically present for the release we
kind of sit and have triage because we
also with Indies often will release and
do the review embargo at the same time
against maximize exposure so will will
sit in a room usually three or four of
us and
launched together and the rule is we get
the most expensive bottle of champagne
we can afford and the cheapest pizza we
can find we have the whole sequence but
yeah it's it's it's intimidating because
on the indie side yes we need the
exposure we need people to be talking
about our game because we can't rely on
to pick on last of us like presumably
tens of millions if not edge again to
the hundreds of millions of marketing
spend which go into making sure that
everyone who buys two games a year
because yeah are you I did get Lou up
because because it was top tier in terms
of reviews like I don't know what their
Metacritic score is but it's like I'd
say low 90s I presume if not higher as
someone who's game is kind of sits
somewhere around usually where we wobble
around the kind of the eight out of ten
with our games which is no small feat
it's ninety one there you go so that
sounds about right
that the the the impact of if one of our
games did manage to get I think Thomas
was alone as probably obviously the
highest mercury of course that's game
but like I think like whatever we were
the the if you educated near 94 nd that
is a massive deal because that's that's
gonna be a conversation in common I know
that's of the other thing is often
you'll find with the indie side of
things that with reviews don't
necessarily correlate with chatter like
we've certainly had games they're
reviewed really well but players weren't
that fussed about but we've also had
vice-versa where like maybe the reviews
have been more varied and but the
audience just really gets into it so
much more chaotic thing to launch then I
think it probably is in triple-a I'm
sure Matt the opposite matters but like
in triple-a I feel like the machine is
already rolling down the hill to an
extent you don't have to rely on oh
sorry Tripoli's don't have to rely on
reviews for marketing they use their
marketing budget for that whereas Indies
literally is what of mouth you need
people to hear about your game and the
best time to do that is when it comes
out so we have usually our embargo is I
think people think that Indies hold back
their reviews until launch because we
want to like lie to the consumer or a
trigger consumer I've seen that on
line it's not it's because we need to
make sure that when you hear about our
game you can buy it immediately this
whole like limbo that's something like
last of us can live in now where I'm
getting excited because I've read that
I've seen the review bars I've seen that
it's a good game but I can't get my
hands on it till Friday
like that's planning content is this
month belongs to the Last of Us part two
I need to get out as much content about
that thing as I can because it will
trend the whole month and I know that
so I'm also feeding in fact what I'm
fighting as well I can't cuz I and and
I've done it I've we offer ever feel
like this the dumbest business decision
I ever made was releasing volume which
was a decent stealth game I think two
weeks after Metal Gear Solid 5 into
exactly the situation you're describing
and we had to like we we didn't we had
to release that game when we released it
we're an indie team like we couldn't
just sit on it for six months from I
know like Kingdoms of Amalur which I
absolutely love is being remastered
because it's now owned by THQ nautic
came out around the same time as one of
the dragon ages I don't remember exactly
but that meant that because EA was
publisher for both of them Kingdoms of
Amalur just didn't really get marketed
and I loved that game so yeah so for me
that's where the meta Creek thing is I'd
honestly like creatively I find I don't
find that like a launch day reviews
super informative like in terms of like
what I've done because bluntly as
consumer focus they're usually the
things we already have spreadsheets
about like with like in terms of like
what the 10 bullet points are like these
the five positives these the flies net
five negatives most developers go into
launch knowing what that list probably
is gonna be where it gets interesting
and where I am like intrigued by reviews
is the waiting he's like I think that's
where a lot of the subjectivity of
reviews comes in is like how much
they're gonna forgive us for this
problem versus how much they're gonna
love this thing you know and and that's
where you know if you look at the
reviews for I guess any of our games
really if you look at five reviews
you're gonna see the same issues
positive and negative kind of touched on
in all the reviews but for one critic
that that problem was insurmountable and
stressed them out on your in the game
and for another critic they didn't care
about
issue and that's where the wobble comes
in which is interesting but not it's
interesting academically but it's not
like I don't judge what I'm gonna do in
future based on what really interests me
is it's months and years later the kind
of more academic kind of reviews that
happen and more kind of not necessary
even reviews but like critical
discussion features where you see like
or like YouTube like deep dive kind of
there's one I was watching earlier with
someone this is it's three professors
doing analysis on the cultural stuff in
subsurface circular which is a game that
does touch on some things which are kind
of I think potentially relevant right
now but stuff that I wouldn't that you
don't see in a consumer review that's
gonna tell you whether a games worth
your 5 bucks but it's really interesting
just to watch three very clever people
talk about something I made for an hour
and really dig in on and it gives me new
perspectives there's a there's a thing
in that game which I wrote as sorry I'm
just rambling about myself I apologize
but like there's a there's an idea in
that game which is the robots temper
their speech when talking to humans and
the only and and it's talked about a bit
in the game and the only reason I exist
is just as a writer that felt like
something a I would have to do robots
would have to kind of Kate as the
audience and then you have like you know
a academic who studies conversations
between people of different races and
how people kind of temper their speech
in different groups or when people are
talking outside of their gender or when
two people are talking out spacely to
another group of how that interface
changes when when that person's like and
now analyzing my demin knowing this is a
really clever dissection of that that's
amazing as a creator because you're
watching that you're like I had no idea
about any of what that person's talking
about but Dan that's an interesting take
your game anymore it's everyone's game
and I yeah that's so enriching that
stuff I love and consume and if you've
ever made like a bad essay about one of
my games I've probably read it because
I'm just fascinated by it those day
reviews I'm more playing the business
owner who wants to make sure my guys
have jobs next week there's no type but
like you know I mean I guess it's a
different there's a with regard to that
specific thread of
the impact on Indies vs. triple A's and
and how much that the discoverability of
a title can be influenced there's a
pretty good
Jason roar the indie developer did a GDC
talk a couple of years ago about where
he was analyzing that the topic of the
day at the time was the indie pocalypse
and he was going to describe one of my
games interestingly and genuinely that
doctor my first use of indie pocalypse
was used in a pretty poorly researched
thing about how volume was a credit was
a financial failure boy what is that
what is that be successful what is that
typically what is that supposed to
indicate what is what is indie pocalypse
supposed to be so it was a term it was
Austin sensor I'm speaking all over his
point but back in like 2015 represented
better than I will back in 2015
basically reality was hitting the indie
space like there'd been indie game the
movie which I think releasing about 2011
2010 you had a lot of Indies a lot of
people like me who basically when we
went to go make our games and a small
minority of us managed to have you know
hit indie games that did well and set us
up and I'll see a lot of people we're
not having that success and it that kind
of but there was definitely a perception
that all indie games are those exception
that indie was over and specifically be
a word in deep Apocalypse was used in an
article by someone it was a really silly
article but it was basically comparing
Thomas was alone sales over three years
two volumes first week and saying the
volume sales were lower than Thomas was
alone which was bad was load had been
out for three years I made so so
obviously was a different comparison to
make and it was and that's where the end
apocalypse tone was used but yes it was
this general sense that maybe the bubble
was bursting on indie basically the way
the way the first time I was made aware
of that term was a conversation with the
banner saga team because banner saga one
came out 2014 and I remember the the art
director Arnie Jorgenson saying that
that month on steam 71 I think some ish
I feel like 71 is the number he told me
it was 70 something 70 games shipped on
Steam that month in 21
14 by the time 2016 came and Banner Saga
2 was shipping which also did not open
as strong financially as banner saga 1
he said it was 400 in something games
this month on stevis yeah and the same
thing Banner Saga 3 was 2018 and it was
the same thing it was like nine hundred
games shipped or whatever that month and
so the indie pocalypse was the idea that
it has gotten exponentially it's harder
to stand out and so the diamonds in the
rough are increasingly that Jason more
diamonds you have to be much better now
like I look at some of they told us was
learnin like if that came out now that
would game would not have found an
audience like you would just have been
so hard to say but the the the takeaway
of of Jason roar in the GDC talked about
this was that he said the thing that's
interesting is that the absolute number
not the percentage but the absolute
number of indie game any games that are
a legitimate full-blown hit each year
has stayed quite constant he goes
there's very little variation it's just
there with in a pool of increasingly
larger games but interestingly enough to
the point and the reason I thought of it
was that their press coverage either in
the form of reviews or features seemed
to make no impact because he said he
brings up case two or it made it less
impact in his then one might think and I
don't know to the extent that I might be
misrepresenting the takeaway I watched
this a couple years ago and so it's it's
on its face it sounds like he's
disagreeing with you I don't want to put
those words in his mouth though so I
there's more nuance to it I'm sure is
this something I could look up Boston
don't know yeah Jay simmer I've seen
it's the did a DC talk in 2018 I think
it was then yeah so he's right like to
be clear I think all points kind of
they're different but I think they do
align in the sense of I see there are
different kinds of indie developers now
I'm very much a traditional press indeed
people have heard of me and I get
coverage and that is how my game sell
but there are totally like indie games
on Steam that no one watching this has
heard of that have sold 10 million units
that was and that was one of his doing
my reasons exist
you know what roblox is about cuz I have
no [ __ ] idea but there's a whole
audience of millions of people play in
that like it that just beyond my base
yeah yeah yeah if you think of it as
like a valley of like indie darling over
here which I guess is devs like me dams
like the disco Elysium guys like people
who superhot those kind of get those
indie games that's makes one super and
then you've got all these games that
you've never heard of but just really
connected and then in the middle you've
just got this kind of pit which is where
most games so here's my question then
what is the point of scores are you
calling my music the point
I mean I don't know I'm running a long
con here and just hoping like is just to
inform consumers who are making an
expensive purchasing decision on if they
would like the thing the thing that I
suggest most consumers do which most
don't do because it requires an
investment and I've spoken before about
how I think the journalists and the
public were always supposed to work
together from the foundations of
journalism and that hasn't quite
happened um you should find a reviewer
who you or or several that you align
with and follow them rather than
following an outlet basically that's
that's the idea
skulls themselves are almost necessary
by virtue of how quickly we consume
things now so I feel like almost every
writer I ever speak to is always like I
wish I could get rid of them I hate them
I'm executive producer of reviews at
inside gaming and we don't do schools I
don't want to do them they suck if
they're annoying but audiences
despite also seeming to agree if you
read the comments put so much stock in
them they talk about them they share
them BAE screenshot them they say ten
out of ten this is part of the
conversation so it's this like cycle
that's perpetuated by both sides whether
if you as a giving scores in part
because then you'll get screenshotted
and Naughty Dog will put your outlet in
a tweet I'm sure it's not you know I'm
not saying that that's an incentive to
give a ten out of ten but it does mean
that you'll get screenshotted and shared
by a bunch of people and your outlet
will be shared
having that extremely easy to
communicate information in a little just
four digits usually an audience is like
just talk about them constantly so so
it's the Itchy scores to convey the
information as succinctly as possible
basically well plus and you've brought
up before as I recall that that from a
traffic metric on the sites the reviews
that have scores get way more readers
like like in terms of selling ads on
your site for for you know click-through
and stuff like that
scored reviews are just far more
valuable absolutely every time yeah
they're just so much more important to
conversation for whatever reason even
though I think we kind of all agree the
best super reductive and it's also
really hard like if you're reviewing
something that's really complex and you
have to give it a score that's the part
that I always dread when we talked about
this before - especially if it's not a
scale like 1 to 10 yeah like ah is the
IGN review scale you can read publicly
it's listed the way that if you're
having trouble with the score that
reviews it Oh too bad Dan Stapleton will
do it is if I walked up to you on the
street and asked you what you thought of
this game what would be the word that
you would give me 10 is masterpiece 9 is
amazing 5 is mediocre so if I'm gonna
say good it's gonna be a 7 if I say
great it's gonna be an 8 and like that's
such a simple way to do it but that's
the way he's like if you're having
trouble literally what would would you
give me if I walked up to you on the
street because I'm not gonna say breath
of the wild is good I'm gonna say breath
of the wild is absolutely incredible and
you should play it
he's like sounds like a tent doesn't it
really yeah but we could all agree that
that even those terms right there are
incredibly subjective of course yeah
like oh dear Austin things bad but I
think that's a Lana's point right that
that if I follow it by framing it as I
follow Alana's reviews or I follow XYZ
person's reviews the subjectivity you
absorb textual eyes their vocabulary
exactly objective within that it's like
if you've got a friend who do you think
has good taste in movies when that
friend is like you've got to watch this
people have different values so you
agree with like generally is the best
person to ask like I know that
so uh if my friend Jess likes a certain
movie I'm probably gonna like it because
we have really similar taste in movies
and occasionally that doesn't align she
liked the lighthouse and I thought it
was dumb I'll see that movie by mean no
emotion but the most part I know that
Jess and I aligned so she's the person
that I'm going to ask about maybe so it
really should walk that way wipes with
YouTube as well
you should find review as you like
rather than outlets you like and that's
like a complicated problem surrounding
reviews to is well why did this game
that has more features get a lower score
than this game when that came out first
or whatever two different reviewers it
walk across the website that IGN
guideline is fascinating to think of
because it really does own the
subjectivity on the flip side of that a
number of years every now and again I'm
asked to be a judge in this particular
composer it's like a workshop thing that
that that ASCAP the American Society of
Composers Authors and publishers which
is like a royalty organization that pays
out for royalties or in done music this
well I know there's more information
than needed but they do a composer
workshop each summer where it's
completely free and you get like a 60
piece full orchestra of Hollywood studio
musicians recorded at Fox out of it for
free and so it's very competitive to get
into and the idea is that it's like
night classes where you go and you know
they give you an opportunity to you get
mentored by a lot of the the biggest
names in the business you know they'll
take you on a visit to like Hans Zimmer
studio and he'll sit and talk to
everybody for an hour or two and and and
I I did it as a student maybe 12 years
ago or something and then they've asked
me to be one of the applicant judges
since then and they take the opposite
stance where you're judging people some
music that's the sole thing that you're
asked to like you can read their cover
letter which is usually a bio but the
idea is listen to their music they have
very specific things they're asked to
send and then you have very specific
criteria that you judge their music by
where you try to distill different sort
of components of their music like you
you study the production value of it but
then
you assign everything a score there's
like six or seven or eight metrics that
you judge and then those scores are
weighted so obviously the subjectivity
of it is in the weighting of the scores
but for example production value like if
it's supposed to be live orchestra but
they're only doing it in GarageBand on
their computer because they can't afford
a real Orchestra or even like high-end
samples production value is the least
valuable score but it is a thing to
consider so the idea is we don't want to
hold them accountable to the idea that
they may not have been able to afford
something that wanted their competitors
but it's not worth zero in the
conversation it's just worth less so if
I give someone a three out of ten on
production value like it could be the
most brilliant piece of music ever
written but it just sounds the sonic
impact of it to my ears is bad and only
because I'm a professional composer can
I still that evaluate that buried within
that bad sound is a good piece of music
it's like it'd be like listening to a
you know a bad performance at a live
show where you're like I know I love
that song but that that band sucked in
their cover of it's like almost kind of
think of it like that
I I am not overly penalizing them for
that whereas like raw composition is
extremely valuable so if I'm medium on
that but they've produced the hell out
of it because they're like some
billionaires kid that doesn't that
doesn't give them a leg up actually if
if I may there there's like it there was
a competition that I was in that
similarly one of the criteria or one of
the categories you were voted on was
song selection so I was like the
interesting should you have chosen that
song for you to sing so I think that
there's and this goes to games as well
as far as how you should be graded if
you can't do a certain thing well like
you just don't have the resources to be
able to do it and I know that with the
new hardware everything those some of
the that disparity between what a
triple-a and a triple-a can do is
getting a little bit more narrow right
but like if you can't do a big graphics
forward game then don't do a game that
is so graphics intensive do something
that is more scalable so I would be able
to judge someone on that goal well you
can't we don't have
no the the money that Naughty Dog has to
be able to throw at graphics it's like
then don't make that game so if you
don't have a big sound library don't do
a bit and this is like a one-time don't
do a big string arrangement then what's
it what's a more interesting voice that
you can use do some Piccolo's like yeah
you're always the person that goes if I
hear a piano in an orchestra I'm like ah
it's boring because it takes up so much
bandwidth do something different and I
would much rather hear it's like yeah I
use like clavos you know or use you know
some kind of weird instrumentation to do
a different voicing of that like that's
that's really really interesting I think
you should be judged on the resources
what you use with what you had for it to
be clear sorry I just just address that
super quick that to be clear within that
thing that I was talking about there
there were enough criteria that I think
it did kind of pass all that around and
then the result is you know they get a
final score and that final score out of
100 or whatever that is they're kind of
ranking and then amongst like the top
twenty ten are chosen by then handing it
over to the final like Council or
whoever the final arbiters and to me it
was a way to it was a council reviews
before that seemed like they had a
similar grade I it's it's like my old
favorite one of my favorite colbert
report bits of all time was when the baz
lurman tread carefully on this one
austin you're talking to it Ozzy the
Great Gatsby came out and Colbert did a
whole episode of our whole week even I
think about the Great Gatsby and and
there was an episode where he he goes to
ask Carey Mulligan and and then they
both the bit is that they neither have
read it
and and so she's he's like how could you
not have read it like you're in it what
about even reading the script and she
goes honestly I can't read they just put
peanut butter on the roof of my mouth
like a dog and then overdub me with
James Franco anyway it was her going I
can't read that you just flashed back in
my mind and it makes me sad that the
Colbert Report doesn't exist anymore
alright so I have to say this episode
all right well he finished his tangent
with that I was gonna say I one of the
first websites that I worked for him cuz
I've worked for a lot of weird websites
because you know when you're starting
out writing and you you need to get
published and also I really needed at it
is because I needed help
I just wrote for a bunch of like sites
that nobody's hurdled it didn't
necessarily have their [ __ ] together
that I didn't know at a time either no
shame in working for them you got you
got to do what you can to get published
but one of the first ones that I ever
wrote for had a score system that on
paper I think a lot of games community
think that they want but thinking back
to it it didn't make any sense
well you had categories that you would
score out of 5 so that was one yeah
exactly
audio one for gameplay one for Story one
for replayability and one for like late
nineties GameSpot that kind of like PC
gamer I'm saying it was like that it was
like a hangover from not a very very but
it meant that each of those categories
was weighted the exact same amount and
that you would you know you score them
all out of five and then average it and
then that was how you would figure out
your score and it it's easy to do that
from a writer's perspective to be like
yeah this is strong well this is not but
it doesn't make any sense to wait
graphical quality the same as audio in a
game that is about an audio experience
like a child of Eden I'm not going to
rate the story in child of Eden as
though it matters compared to gameplay
or audio it just doesn't make any sense
to approach reviews that way and that's
part of where reviews become subjective
is kind of - I think you were saying at
earlier Mike which specific parts of
which thing you as a reviewer care about
the most
I remember when we were reviewing breath
of the wild at IGN only
three of us had it in the office and it
was is this going to be a ten because we
were all completely enamored with it I
absolutely loved that game and I
remember the first time that I did one
of the shrines that has gyro controls
which means you have to physically move
the switch to like get a ball to go
somewhere
it was awful just awful something that
should have taken a couple of minutes
took me 20 minutes because it was
fundamentally broken and I walked into
the room where Jose Otero who is
reviewing and now actually works at
Nintendo which keeps happening at IGN
that Nintendo people keep going to work
but I was like a copy of ten can't be a
ten this is broken this is fundamentally
broken and it's infuriating and there
are I think three shrines like that
which is nothing but I was like you
can't do it and he was like what do you
mean it was like I I can't get through
this pot without wanting to bang my head
against a wall and is prohibitive and it
is required for you to do it he was like
I don't think that matters in the grand
scheme of things but I did I wouldn't
have given that game of ten because I
thought that those controls were bad
enough that it caught a point off maybe
I would have been a nine point nine but
I still was like no that's unexcusable
in a game where gameplay should be king
and we care so much about these physics
to praise the physics at one point I'm
gonna have this be broken I can't do it
but he was like but I don't feel that
way about I don't feel as strongly about
that thing not walking as you do and
that comes to the point of ten out of
ten not meeting perfect because nothing
is perfect that IGN article I was
talking about that literally goes over
what their abuse goes means says at the
very top gay reviews this objective
everything has flaws so here's a
question I've made several of our games
are nine on ones website six on another
and it's it's like I see that and it's
like and what you don't one the six but
like it's like you're like at least I
made something interesting into your
point when you were mentioning my
committed ago that like the reasons for
the six versus the nine is all the same
ingredients of reasons but with 100 to
Alana's point certain things are more
detrimental to some or more empowering
or positive for some and that's to me is
always the really interesting thing you
could do about that it's just some
things not with an objective
yeah there's no objective game
design solution to 50% of our players
like that 50% oh there is no there's no
fix and arguably there shouldn't be you
should do the thing you think should be
right so here's a question do you think
then that that scores should exist for
the sake of the developer or for the
sake of the consumer consumer but they
have no impact on them all right and
that is probably an ongoing conversation
the industry needs to have but reviews
are intended and I feel like it's just
everything's gotten out of hand with
media distrust and some of which is
deserved
the the purpose is to tell someone
especially in Australia what games $100
if that 100 dollars should be spent on
this game of us is this game especially
for people who can't afford to buy every
game that comes out of here the purpose
is to tell you should you be spending
your money and it is a lot of money on
this one thing that is that is the point
yeah I guess you're right if that's not
walking and it's also that [ __ ]
journalists can't compete with the
marketing machines so much mystery but
who cares more about that score like who
do you think it has more impact on does
it have more impact on if if just using
responsive data right if the consumers
gonna buy that game they're gonna
pre-order they gave they're not gonna
buy that game regardless of what it is
and probably what's gonna determine
whether they buy it or not is the price
right so if it's 60 they're like ah I
know those the scores are great but I
just don't think that's gonna be my
maybe word of mouth of someone going you
have to play this game is gonna mean
more to them or it drops from 60 to 50
or 49 or they buy it used or whatever
they're like or the Steam sale or
whatever there's like okay now I apply
you know it there's more than the score
or it's the culmination of the score and
the price you know who knows but by and
large if we're just talking about scores
it seems to me that the quarry bar logs
and the Neil druckmann and the Mike
Bethel's and everything that are
planning events around review scores are
about to come out that's who it's that's
who it's for it's about hey dev you did
this this is what we think of it for
good
bad and the onus is upon us that is
incumbent upon us to write a review that
explains our score in a meaningful and
cogent way that you go the thing that
you worked for three years six years two
years 18 months whatever on that thing
we thought this about and that the other
thing we thought this about and here's
your score sorry from my perspective
that's not what writers I think we are
but like whoa I'm gonna say from my side
because I because I've been there I've
had like friends and acquaintances write
bad reviews of my stuff and I've had
people I genuinely don't like write good
stuff about my stuff so I've been in
both sides of this and it's genuinely
not impacted my opinion either of those
groups like I think it's I don't take it
personally I try not to I think it's
it's you know it sucks you see a bad
school but like I don't I am considering
a conversation it's a conversation I'm
listening in on that's journalists
talking to the consumer I'm I'm over
here I'm like but I also think you're
right Troy and I hadn't even really
thought about it that as it stands right
now publishers and devs probably do care
more about schools than the public do
and I would consider that to be a
problem I mean especially in the case of
Fallout New Vegas they didn't get
bonuses because they got an 84 on
Metacritic rather than an 85 I use that
all the time I use that example all the
time there there are bonus structures
and there are there's there's structure
built around so how else could you
quantify and qualify if you hit your
street date if you do this amount of
sales if you do this madam preorder
sales it determines marketing dollars if
you're like we are tracking or trending
towards but based on pre-orders we will
sell this amount there there is a skirt
there's a spreadsheet that is done and
they are already deciding on whether or
not they're going to do a prequel or do
a sequel based upon free
orders for a game that isn't come out
yet so mean that the Metacritic the
Metacritic specific bonus is that thing
I've not seen that in a contract for a
while like on my scale you would
probably know you probably know better
because more people are probably looking
at it something that's subjective it's
just so shitty it goes further actually
as well the biggest problem with it
beyond just the the letting journalists
decide how much my team gave my team
have jobs the the main problem I have
with actually as a metric is you can
absolutely pay me based on my Metacritic
score if you let me make every creative
decision and define exactly what the
thing we're making is and make it the
way I want to make it and obviously
these relationships with publishers and
more partnerships right you're having
conversations anyway they might want to
do something they might have a
difference of opinion they might have
something where they want they want this
feature to be in there but not this
thing and you kind of work it's a
collaboration so the idea that the
Metacritic will only impact one party
out of that relationship it seems like
it's it's letting the publisher wash
their hands of it and go you didn't
deliver so for you whereas happy you
know if every if every review yeah like
like how many games have been shipped
with like terrible multiplayer modes
right there have dented their Metacritic
scores the dev teams in most cases don't
want to do that ones pushing for the
multiplayer you know and that's and so
therefore that's that's I think that's
where most developers too much
developers think it's fair to like be
judged and paid on how good the stuff we
make is that that's valid but when we're
not in complete control of what that
thing is and that's when people who take
pride in their work are like well that's
not fair that's that's you know that's
that's a that's shaky but I wouldn't I
wouldn't sign a contract like that and I
think I think they are at least at my
scale those don't really exist in the
same way or or yeah I can you speak for
what I've seen Mike it's not no one no
one's have nerve to come with me with
that contract for what it's worth on the
music side I have never once had that
I've never even heard of it with
composers because generally speaking
there's no bonuses on the table
regardless it's always a no it's always
an interesting
there are exceptions and obviously the
more indie it is the more that is viably
part of the conversation because the the
developers are often very sympathetic to
it's also worth it's sorry it's also
worth saying like I'm sorry completely
you're very rude apologies it's also
it's also worth saying that the bonus
thing in itself like that is in terms of
like internal developments do so like
Naughty Dog for example who is owned by
Sony that they will have bone
instructions and that kind of thing in
place the vast majority of games you
play are made by publish apartment with
a developer publisher puts up the money
and marketing developer makes the game
that's how most games that people play
are so I'm speaking to you as don't know
everyone on this call knows that um but
like the the reality there has shifted
massively in the last 5-10 years cuz
there's so many more publishers now that
actually those deals are much more
reasonable in terms of they're not
necessarily it used to be that you'd
make a game and then you maybe a bonus
if it sold well or not nowadays most of
those deals are percentage splits
because those numbers are no longer
mysterious you can't hide from a
developer how many units are games sold
because those numbers attract in so many
places there's no there's also more
competition between publishers to get
you know developers especially
developers with a reputation so there's
there's a nice evening out now but
actually we're all kind of getting paid
based on how well this thing sells so
that metric I think is raised in
importance versus although that said
composers do typically still as because
we're in this third category of we're
not the publisher obviously but we're
actually on paper not the developer
either we are an independent contractor
and the and the the subtext of that is
almost always you know how much does it
cost for us to pay you for your services
and then make you go away because we
don't have a long term relationship with
you the way we do with the developer but
you also assume absolutely no risk me
yeah like the same same thing as me I
don't assume any risk that that's that's
I've I actually love deals where I'm
assuming the risk so do I so do I by the
way
on certain things but by and large when
it's when you're brought in it's like
all right you're the composer you're
gonna do this thing if this game doesn't
tank you still got paid it's not as as
much as that and then there's other
opportunities you're like look if you're
willing to come in with us and say you
may not make as much on the front end
but if this thing blows up then you get
something on the back end but you're
gonna have to give up something in the
front you can't get we're gonna pay you
what you baked and then also you get
extra on top this isn't a whole other
conversation as far as when you start
getting into the residual and bonuses
and everything but that's but you're
absolutely right and that's partly why I
don't I've never had an issue with the
fact that we're treated differently
we're also not full-time employees I
mean most composer contracts are based
around the amount of the work yeah
they're mounted filter rounds in most
cases yeah which I have all kinds of
issues with but but setting that aside
it makes it it's about the quantity of
final product regardless of how much
iteration and revision and whatever is
required to get there its amount you're
going to deliver us this sized package
in the end and as opposed to a developer
which is you're going to give us this
many hours per day per week of your life
for the next four maybe the indefinite
future right because almost all because
composers are not paid by the hour
unless they're a staff job which is the
the the absolute minority of composers
the result is that almost all composers
are simultaneously composers that have
some level of career going working on
multiple things they're almost always
working on multiple things at a time
which is another reason why it's
perfectly fair because a composers in a
position to be able to do that it's all
the more fair to have a little bit more
of a cut and dry like here's your here's
the amount of money for the services
rendered regardless of how much time it
needs as long as we all agree on the
quality of the final result we don't
really care how much time it takes you
that can get dicey obviously because
sometimes when a schedule pushes that
amount of money that was perfectly
acceptable for a nine-month turnaround
has become now like journey is an
example I don't mind being transparent
about like my that game was almost
triple
the amount of time than the original
budget of course all the developers had
their salaries just extend until the
very end my pay was completely
unaffected
in fact my pay was unaffected but the
but the production budget came under
threat because now the game's budget was
so much more than Sony was originally
wanting to spend that it went from
absolutely we're gonna hire an orchestra
to we're probably not gonna hire an
orchestra anymore because it's taken so
much longer I know all this is where
there's two composers it's never fun
yeah it's it's I bring it all up like in
contrast to that the Banner Saga was a
game where they they did cut me in and
and I was I was essentially wedded to
the developers in that way and so the
little money they were able to give me I
spent a hundred percent of it on hiring
the orchestra and I was I went unpaid
completely made zero and then said let's
roll the dice on the aggregate of the
combination of soundtrack album sales
and the game sales and I loved that I
was in the same exact position as then
because obviously they were in Indy they
were paying for that game off of a
Kickstarter they were not paying
themselves a salary I mean they were
paying their bills that's part of what
the Kickstarter did but on paper they
were essentially living off their
savings from their from their prior
bioware days and so I like that deal but
anyway that that's all just say it's a
ended way of saying that reviews I have
never had a bonus I'm tied to a review
and for I think perfectly fair reasons I
would never saw you guys I'm supposed to
be live in ten minutes
oh sure but I didn't want to say fast
Austin if you can't answer quickly I
know I'm playing with fire here before
buying a game or two a game has worked
on yeah so I've always been fascinated
by it I have two angles my super quick
answer I have two angles on when reading
a review first and foremost I love
working on games because of who I get to
work with so when I read a review that's
glowing I get excited because it's like
that person that I probably by this
point really adore and cherish having
having
through the process together that review
means I get to celebrate 99% of the
review is about their work if not a
hundred because I'm so I'm I'm not that
often mentioned in the reviews of most
most games reviews don't make a point of
talking about music or they'll give it a
passing mention of like yeah the score
was pretty good of course every now and
again they'll they'll say it was very
distracting or they'll hate it and then
I have been very lucky that every now
and again they make a big point of
talking about the music but by and large
it's not the focus of the review because
it's also not the focus of the consumer
which is perfectly fair I don't have any
issue with that so for me it becomes a
celebration it's like with Troy's text
Anil it becomes like like whenever I
read a great review of John with hex my
first thought is that makes me [ __ ]
stoked for Mike because he put in the
work he took the risk he did all of that
and here's somebody who saw that and saw
the positives there and and shared it
with the world and that makes me happy
the subset of that is obviously there is
the narcissistic every now and again
someone does write something really nice
about my work on a game and and when I
find that in a review it feels nice
because they're not incentivized to pay
attention to that element of the game
and it's so they're I can't deny that it
it's a it's a nice moment to be
discovered there but the only the only
the single point I'll add is that the
only time a review has ever made a big
impact on me was when journey came out
because I've never had a game so widely
reveai never had anything so widely
reviewed the game the game was
everywhere overnight and I genuinely
until the reviews hit which was out
about a week before the game was
available to players I had no idea if
anyone would like it or hate it or it
was such a mystery because I thought we
made the game we set out to make but
they might hose this as pretentious
garbage that no and I just thought it
could be a disaster and I and I had no
clue it literally was an open field
where anything felt possible and then
the first review was like wow this is
really great or what and then the second
and then you start reading reviews that
are like this is revelatory this is the
defining lot
and I'm like holy [ __ ] and it was like
this surreal and it was all the reviews
that were driving these these very
articulate reasoned journalistic
analyses as to why they thought it was
good it was just the most surreal and to
this day one of the most unbelievable
hard to believe it actually happened
kind of experiences never since then
have I put that much stock in them
though other than to celebrate the
achievements of like my friends reviews
are for the dev reviews or for the dev
reviews are for the day that's if I come
for just one minute all right hurry up I
have to be live I'm sorry I just know I
die I I think I'm I just I'm just so
jealous of that perspective like to be
able to be kind of removed to that
extent like you know it's a privileged
position cheerleader to kind of be a
kind of that's how I do I think you're
massively I think you're massively
diminishing your impact obviously you
try in Austin you've made several of the
games the or you're as much a developer
as anyone else on those teams but like
the there is yeah I'm very envious of
that kind just being able to enjoy
someone else's success with the game I
feel that way when I see of reviews of
other indie game yes nice yeah but for
me it's too tied up in like the team I'm
trying to look after in all that stuff
that's why when the sales that's that's
a perfect microcosm of why windows come
in you should be the primary beneficiary
over someone like me because you have
assumed that risk I will shut up